when you know different companies or
organizations we're like oh my god you
know
kind of shut down close the windows uh
you know let us just go through it
um they're behind and this year was
actually a huge
test for you know agility
taking risks uh putting yourself out
there
being more you know humble uh you know
with your customers and with the you
know the ecosystem
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford corporate innovation is more
and more relevant
today important for everyone meet romy
davidore
director of catalyst dail in 2018
romy joined the israel innovation
institute with a clear vision of forming
a professional
first of its kind community in the field
of innovation management in
organizations
corporates and on a geographical level
following this passion
romney co-founded and today the director
of catalyst dial community
with more than 2 300 community members
200 innovation managers
and 100 and more professionals all part
of the ecosystem
romy davidor welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm doing well michael thank you very
nice to be here with you
i it's an honor having you here talking
about corporate innovation and
innovation management community building
a directorate catalyst ielts working
with the israeli ecosystem
and and all around innovation what does
innovation even mean and
and how does it actually get translated
into corporates
in a corporate setting which you know a
lot of times is a
is far from being synonymous with
innovation
romy what what is innovation in your
eyes
wow um it's interesting that you were
asking me this is the first question
because this is the first question that
um i'm asking on a new podcast that i'm
running with
a very good friend of mine and a
colleague which is still not
out it's not in the air it's called the
the the transformators
um and this is the first question that
we ask each innovation
uh manager that we are hosting because
each person and each innovation leader
really sees
innovation in a different way and in my
perspective
innovation is is a way to create a
change
either in change management or using
technology creating
a new value for an acute problem or a
challenge
this is innovation innovation has to be
connected to the core business
and has to be connected to the strategy
of the organization
um this is when true innovation actually
occurs and can be in help
right and so you know when you talk
about all of that it what what is
innovation than in the context of
corporates and specifically into the
israel ecosystem
okay so maybe to take um you know take
it
a bit back to people that don't know
catalyst il or the israeli innovation
institute so
um i joined in uh the israeli innovation
institute with a very
clear vision of forming a professional
first of its kind uh community in the
field of innovation management
in organizations corporate and also on a
geographical level
um following this passion actually i was
um
the co-founder and uh today the director
of catalyst daily community it has
over 2500 community members
over 230 innovation managers uh yeah
that i'm in touch with on a daily basis
across all companies in the israeli
market and
over you know hundreds of different
professionals from the ecosystem
and when we first formed catalyst dail
we saw that there is a huge need for a
community for an umbrella organization
for all innovation leaders in israel
it's quite a new profession you know
everybody knows what's a cfo a cdo
in each different corporate innovation
looks different
and it answers a different need and we
say okay well
if we want to make sure that more and
more innovation
is implemented in the in you know
israeli companies
and for the benefit of you know whoever
lives here
we want to make sure that we strengthen
the innovation leader or manager in
different
corporates and different organizations
and
it sounds it sounds very vague maybe but
it means to make sure that more
innovation managers
actually know how to bring value to
their own organization
and the very first steps in whatever
company the innovation
leader is at is actually understanding
the challenges what are the acute
and most pain uh painful points that
innovation can be in health
and when we talk about innovation in
corporate it can be working with the
ecosystem
meaning working with academia working
with accelerators working
of course with startups that we have so
many here in israel in different fields
and it all it also means working
internally
and seeing how you know different people
in different departments can actually
uh be in help uh and you know bringing
different um
you know professional work that they're
already doing in the organization
to the benefit of the organization and
sometimes
this is actually kind of a blind spot um
most innovation managers in israel
because we're living in the startup
nation
go outside to the ecosystem
and not many of them actually look
internally into the uh
organization so this is kind of the way
i see it in my perspective
so let's you know do a deep dive into an
organization and
you know what what are some of the you
know the intricacies
i understand you know innovation as a
small group of people
you know you're defining a new culture
you're defining you know um
you're defining a an innovation in the
essence of creating a new company once
you're at a big company
you're starting to see things moving a
little bit slower for a good reason
because
you've now built a world around you and
the world works and
you know you want to move fast and break
things but you don't really want to
break things because you
it works and and you're dependent on
that so what walk me through
exactly you know how a corporate looks
top down
and and where does the innovation lie
within a big corporate like that and how
do things actually move
so i'll divide um you know my answer i
think you know
it has a different different perspective
so when people ask me
um you know on an organizational level
and if we're looking at a structure
where should this innovation manager be
placed at and i say
it has to be um exactly near and under
the ceo
um if the innovation manager is not
reporting to the ceo and top management
um it's a huge huge factor because
um it means that usually this innovation
leader will probably go
and do things that are not in the core
business and
and that and that's fine you know
there's a lot of innovation
um movements that are not for core
business you know for employer branding
for um you know making sure that it's
fun and
innovation you know everybody wants to
be branded with innovation
and um i'm sorry for you know i'm of
course i'm i have
um you know this is not how i think
innovation should serve you know a
company but a lot of companies
are still doesn't have you know the
muscle and the understanding of making
sure that innovation
it has to be in the core meaning with
the ceo
and it means that you know if it's with
the ceo it has
budgets and you know allocating budgets
for pocs
for trial and error for you know being
more agile to also failing in innovation
and it's a huge you know
there's a huge talk about failure that
it's kind of beneath
you know the layers but if a corporate
really wants to manage innovation it has
to be
you know open for real um to fail
because innovation usually fails until
something works
um so we see that you know in this the
the ability to fail or the ability to
you know to do trial and error
really kind of um it really touches a
very fragile part
of the corporate um so this is on an
opt you know the optimum is you know
that the innovation leader is close to
the ceo
has budget has a title has um you know
good uh cooperation and working uh
mythologies
with the different youth sorry with the
different units
um this is always what i have to say you
know that is the most structured way to
manage innovation
right in different corporates um it's
more you know like grassroots it's more
like
bottom up you know there's a lot of
people that really are interested in
innovation they really understand the
value that it can bring to a company
but there's no you know someone with the
title and they start you know bringing
up ideas and different
um you know initiatives from from the
bottom
and this is also very special way
because once things are starting to
bubble up from you know from the bottom
um a good management will understand it
see it and embrace it um
once you know that there is an embrace
and embracion of that
innovation that is coming kind of
growing up from the um from
you know the grassroots um this is also
a way to grow
a person that will actually manage
innovation in a company
but um there's a lot of difficulties um
in this work and as i always say the
persona the person who manages
innovation has a very big attribute to
the succession of you know of the work
um so this is also kind of a point you
know that we see in corporates a person
that you know that
has you know gained the trust uh and the
professionalism working with the
different units will be the one to
actually more
execute innovation uh with the business
units
um you know regarding other people that
you know didn't gain that trust they
don't have that um you know personal
kind of interaction with the different
units
and then we will see that innovation
mostly is you know not really going
anywhere
so it sounds to me that one of the
biggest hurdles and the
friction within corporates is this idea
of failure and harnessing failure and
and that that is on one spectrum so
being able to understand okay where
we're actually opting in for failure at
this point which is very
you know anti-corporate you know mindset
uh
you how you're basically building up all
these walls you're building all these
mechanisms to avoid failure
and then along comes somebody and says
well actually let's now
let's now do everything possible to try
and reach this failure so that we can
learn
i can see why it's there's a little bit
of a dissonance there in the mindset
but then it sounds like the other
important aspect of an innovation
manager is this idea of the integration
between all the all the various parts
and being able to motivate the different
units because you no longer just need to
you know it's fine convincing the ceo
you know in a meeting but then you have
to go and and convince
other team leaders of and other
directors why
they should take the risk and
potentially waste resources
on this you know weird innovation thing
you're trying to do
exactly and i can say that you know in
companies that the innovation leader
um didn't manage to actually
um you know have the other business
units
understand that the innovation manager
is actually kind of like uh
um he's an enabler for the business
units and if the business units don't
see the value that this innovation
leader can bring them you know different
companies
different startups um a new perspective
something that is you know in the trends
now and so if they don't understand it
and
wants to work with the innovation
manager it will completely fail because
the innovation leader is not
you know it doesn't stand alone it has
to it's connected and i always use the
metaphor
uh for like an octopus an innovation
manager it's like in the middle of the
organization
with arms completely until you know the
manufacturing kind of floor
and all the way up to top management and
uh so if the innovation leader is not
able to do this kind of multi uh
outreach in the organization
it will be very difficult for him to
actually execute and actually
work forward uh for the goals that were
kind of listed in the kpis for the
you know for the innovation uh efforts
in the company so is it is there just
you know a handbook of how to do this
that every innovation manager should
should read or because it sounds like
it's it's a it's a
new type of position it's not one that
you hire frequently it's one that is
very specialized and i'm guessing there
is only
a few of those even in the bigger
corporates and so
what what are the ways that today you
know innovation managers are built
are they you know previous entrepreneurs
are they just
directors that have a knack for you know
you know this
this ultra energized personality what
makes a good innovation manager in a
company
it's a very good question um because
it's very interesting to see
the different innovation managers that
have and get the title of being the you
know vp
innovation or innovation leader most of
them actually grow
from the company itself it's being it's
usually somebody that was a very kind of
entrepreneur
um very as you said energetic very
hasn't
been you know inspiration and and really
wants to take things forward
and they usually come from either
business development
strategy a little bit of marketing but
usually they come from that kind of
world
most innovation leaders are actually not
tech people and that could be also a
barrier
um when working with startups so a lot
of innovation leaders don't
usually they need to outsource uh the
due diligence part um
and the part knowing how to actually
evaluate uh
startups so that's you know kind of in a
different subject but
um there's no handbook there's no
guidebook um
there's of course you know catalyst has
a once a year
innovation management course and if i
have to think about you know
kind of um the more crucial maybe tools
or
skills that innovation leaders need
is the thirst the first thing that comes
to my mind is a people's person
an innovation leader must be in close
relationship as i said top management to
all employees across the board
um has to have a way to lead and
convince people to actually
join the innovation efforts um so it has
to be a very you know
strong persuasive very you know knows
the vision that he holds
um but also be able to you know deal
with natural
resistance and you were talking about it
before um natural resistance from within
the organization
nobody wants you know change we hate
change as humans or
on a psychology like level we don't like
change everybody wants to do their job
what they're used to what they best know
um
and for innovation to actually occur
or happen things have to change um so
that is also a very important skill to
know how to manage this kind of
resistance within the organization
um and as i said another thing that is
hugely important is not to be afraid to
fail to
change the agility to change the model
or the plan according to reality
according to the poc results according
to what's going on outside the world we
saw it now during covet 19
a lot of companies um the ones that were
fast
agile were not afraid to do piva
to change to actually uh look different
at their customers look different at
their
um you know things that they sell
they're
these are the companies that actually
grew from this crisis
and when you know different companies or
organizations were like oh my god you
know
kind of shut down close the windows uh
you know let us just go through it
um they're behind and this year was
actually a huge
test for you know agility
taking risks uh putting yourself out
there
being more you know humble uh you know
with your customers and with the you
know the ecosystem so
i think really this was a very important
year for this um
for this subject in organizations
and i think that it's becoming you know
more and more relevant because if you if
you look 50 years ago
at innovation i would argue that a
company would look at it and say
well yes we're making today x amount of
dollars on this product
you know we could make more but in order
to do that we have to waste a bunch of
r d resources and experimentation and
failures
well maybe it's not worth it right now
because you know things are working
let's just go with the flow
we've seen that model work for a while
and then we
come to around the 80s or 90s and we see
this model fail
miserably with companies like
blockbuster and barnes and noble
and these are great companies that i i'm
sure that at some point the management
came together and said
huh maybe we should move our from dvds
to online streaming and i'm sure that
somebody said no
it's not worth it it's too much it would
be too much and and we saw the result
and so i think that today
in 2021 and especially in 2020 like
you're mentioning
we're saying that you know however big
you are
if you don't innovate another startup is
going to come
quickly with a lot of capital there's a
lot you know we're seeing
incredible things happening and you no
longer have this added advantage that
you're
an incumbent with a lot of money because
now things are becoming much more
democratized in this way and so i think
that what you're describing here is the
innovation
management is not just relevant for for
becoming better but it's relevant for
your existence
and today you have to remain relevant
right so romeo it's
go ahead no no i was saying that
i think it's also just to add that um
it's very
i'm very happy with this change because
um it may you know this year really also
bonded together um the ecosystem the
community
the customers with the companies and
it's something that is becoming very
you know important for corporates to
understand that they have to outreach
they have to talk they have to connect
with their customers and with the
community and with the ecosystem
nobody lives in a bubble anymore you
can't just like continue with your bread
and butter
and think that everything will be fine
it's not
um so i think this is a very very good
change that i'm very happy about so
just to add in thank you for that
edition i have some fun questions for
you romy so
start off from hard it will start off
hard and we'll go to harder
uh first a role model somebody real
or not that you would look at as a role
model
wow okay um this is probably gonna be a
bit cheesy
but i don't care um both of my parents
are entrepreneurs themselves um my
two completely different uh you know
fields
my dad was in telecom for many many
years a sailor in
serial entrepreneur um and then 15 years
decided that
he's moving into sustainability impact
clean tech and not
you know giving a hand to anything that
doesn't have a great
and powerful impact to the world so he
really taught me a lot of values about
you know
pushing forward being you know agile
trying you know your hardest all the
time
um not being afraid to have a vision and
everybody's like what's going on what
what will be catalyst a.l
and you know this is what i i had in the
beginning people didn't understand what
we were talking about
and you know today catalyst is catalyst
um and on my
and my mom on the other side also she is
um she's coming from the arts and design
and really um
i think this two kind of worlds
combining together
um really the realistic side of me and
the art
side of me and the you know um the more
creative side
um is very special and you know there
are two of my i think
best role models i love it a favorite
subject in school
peter of course yes
peter did you participate in any plays
musical theater
yeah yeah i was studying actually
theater for
about 10 years since the age of 13 and
until
um i joined the army um so maybe even
earlier from like the age of 12.
um i love theater um i love the text
i love playing i love the arts with it
so theater will be
my favorite of course and the hardest
question of all
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or
other people would choose to describe
you
wow okay
uh i would say leader
uh creative and optimistic
i love it romi
that works perfectly thank you very very
much for coming here
i loved talking innovation i loved
talking you know both
high level uh low level details
um generalizations i think it's the
world is changing before our eyes and
these are exactly the types of
conversations that i that i want to have
when we think about
you know the changing markets and and
how everything is shifting before us and
we're trying to
sort of piece the puzzle together little
by little so thank you very much for
coming here
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
yeah you too thank you have a great day